[Musik]
mein name ist raus war ich 13 jahre alt
und macht momentan jetzt meine
ausbildung als verkäufer ich bin kein
wasser huberty und bin seit oktober 2013
marktleiter ein guter verkäufer muss auf
jeden fall sehr gut umgehen können wie
beraten können und dementsprechend auch
bei dieser problem helfen können das
zwischen werden er muss dem kunden
vermitteln dass er sich hier wohl fühlen
kann und dass er auch immer wieder
kommen kann
[Musik]
im einzelhandel geht es um waren und den
verkauf von verschiedenen produkten wie
zum beispiel obst wurst
käse
und getränken
verkäufer müssen die waren die sie
verkaufen sehr gut kennen
auch die warenkontrolle ist eine
wichtige aufgabe des verkäufers denn der
kunde will immer frische produkte kaufen
[Musik]
verkaufs- und beratungsgespräche mit
kunden sind wichtig auch das bestellen
von waren
die warenannahme und das kassieren mehr
über den beruf des verkäufers erfahrt
ihr im nächsten teil
alles klar
super
dann müssen wir sehen dass wir relativ
fix durchkommen das war schnell arbeiten
dann machen wir folgendes du machst
deine gemüse seite
du musst gleich die aufbauten und du
bist ja jetzt gerade mal den zweiten tag
hier die mast grad einfach folgendes
höchst vorne bei obst nicht mehr los wir
haben ja heute die aktion mit den
kirschen sind ja auch ein sonderangebot
für sieben euro 29 das kino kommen jetzt
gerade frisch vom bauern
wir müssen hier mit rein weil das war
wirklich wunderbar passt da guckst aber
trotzdem mal eben vor durch kirchen sind
sehr anfällig sie werden sehr schnell
schlecht kann natürlich sein dass du die
eine oder andere kirche findet max das
dann hier vorne wo die freie fläche ist
dann musste dann einfach die kirchen
haben
[Musik]
ob du guckst jetzt erst mal dass hier
die kartons einräumt das ist hier vorne
das regal eigentlich siehst du die
ganzen produkte wie findest du auf jeden
fall ein kleiner tipp wenn du gleich
hier die freie fläche hast ne schaust du
gerade nur aufs etikett die letzten zwei
ziffern hier von dieser langen nummer ja
sie stehen immer immer auf dem produkt
drauf hier die 62 passiert mit dem
etikett okay
[Musik]
müssen wir jetzt vielleicht noch mal
gucken ok heute ist recht heiß draußen
das sind alles obstsorten die sind sehr
anfällig auf wärme wenn man hier nicht
immer laufend kontrollieren kann es gut
sein dass wir in einer stunde ganz viele
obst liegen wäre ganz schön wenn du dann
gleich mal drüber guckst wirklich 100
prozent wir müssen immer darauf achten
dass ihr immer alles hundertprozentig
verschaffte ja alles klar
da schau ich mal drüber ja alles klar
wenn mal was man mir fällt gerade auch
die rems jetzt einfach nur davor
er muss schon ein bisschen so start um 8
98 12 da hinten dann wieder andere daten
dann musst du ein bisschen aufpassen
dass du hier den 12.08 ich davor angst
was ja erst die alte ware nach vorne und
die neue dann dahinter
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir gleich eine bestellung
gerät ist auch schon so weit eingestellt
wo wir darauf achten müssen dass wir
hiermit ein lesen mit dem bilden gelben
knopf das ist okay
so
das nimmst du das mde gerät nur selber
in die hand ja mal mit dem berg noch
machst du die bestellung mit dem scanner
dann an das etikett die post auch nichts
ändern da vorne
genau 1 du brauchst nichts machen du
brauchst kein unterdrücken du brauchst
jetzt nicht mehr bestätigen du kannst
immer wieder weiter an dem er irgendwann
gehen und danach bestellen so jetzt
prüfen wir mal eben vorne den
lieferanten einfach mal auch nicht in
was beschäftigt
so wie zeige ich dir gerne mal wie wir
der kontroll vorgang ist kultur ist
direkt beim auspacken
du kannst dann falls was für ihn sollte
direkt anrufen mit viel klarer
das funktioniert auch so so ich brauche
dann bitte aber nur unterstellt alles
klar
ich hätte gerne sein können
wieder eine bestimmte sorte empfehlen
die alemannia
möchten sie die salami pizza zum
beispiel oder zum baguettes oder zum
abend wie genau es ist wunderbar wenn
sie etwas milderes möchten die
klassische deutsche salon es gibt eine
sehr leckere italienische mailänder
salami
das ist eine spanische vergessen die hat
auf einen pfeffer rand dadurch ist hier
was kräftiger auch sehr lecker ist die
französische vergessen ani milden
geschmack auch sehr lecker natur salami
finden sie auch gerne etwas probieren
sie möchten
geschenken
er schmeckt sehr gut an ich denke ich
würde man diese trüffel salami probieren
schmeckt sie dort und sehr interessant
[Musik]
yeah
152 in ordnung 252 außerdem noch ein
boot das erst dann klassische
entschuldigung für zusammen könnten sie
mir verraten wo ich meist finde das
haben sie zwei kinder dankeschön
gemüsekonserven hier finden sie den
meist einmal der großen nase vorne
einmal der kleinbürger
[Musik]
es geht jetzt vor
ganz normaler kassen vorgang ja richtig
zum beispiel wenn ihr haben wollt das
volk gewandt
wir arbeiten sehr fehlen und diesem
scanner cutino hier siehst ganz klein
auf der seite ganze mal drüber ziehen
und dann erscheint der artikel von auf
dem bildschirm ok so tief vorne haben ja
diese liste der eu liste das bedeutet
bei swap ab da kannst du dann schauen
wenn der kunde zum beispiel eine banane
oder mehrere bananen darauf war dann
tipps die wir die nummer 1 macht das
kann mal die 4000 1
[Musik]
7 625 mittel das die bildung der karte
fertige summe genau und dann drückte auf
bezahlung
[Musik]
ja
diese
sehr vielfältig geht natürlich auch in
verschiedene abteilungen richtungen wir
haben den kunden umgehen umgehen soll
zu gehen hat was man bestellungen soll
also wien bestellt wird jede menge
sachen über die wahre allgemeinen laden
aufbau bisher ablaufen sollen er muss
sich mit lebensmitteln auseinandersetzen
er muss spaß an den lebensmittel haben
er muss eigentlich sehr offen sein muss
blitzschnell umschalten können also von
der einen situation in die andere bei
uns ist das so dass letztendlich nicht
nur gelernte mitarbeiter bei uns
anfangen können sondern wir können auch
mit einem aushilfstätigkeit hier
anfangen und schon mal reinschnuppern
oder ein praktikum machen und sich dann
langsam an den beruf gewöhnen und wenn
die sagen mensch das ist was für mich
das passt da habe ich lust daran dann
ist da auf jeden fall einem gespräch
bereit wo wir dann über eine einstellung
sprechen können bzw um ein
einstellungen als auszubildender für
verkäufer verkäuferinnen oder auch
kauffrau oder kaufmann dem einzigen an
unsere azubis die können
wirklich sehr weit kommen also da gehen
wir nun wirklich viele möglichkeiten sie
können hier in erster linie den
ausbildungsberuf als verkäufer
durchlaufen
das wäre eine zweijährige ausbildung und
die zum einzelhandelskaufmann wählen
dreijährige und danach kann man noch
sein handelsfachwirt machen bei uns ist
es so dass wir auch denjenigen die
chance geben hier eine abteilung alleine
zu führen wo er selbst wo er
möglichkeiten hat selbstständig zu
bestellen oder auch die aufbauten und
alles selber machen kann oder wo auch
nachher mehr sachen sind dass er auch in
die marktleitung mit reinkommen kann ein
markt mit führen kann erst mal als
substitut später eventuell sogar als
marktleiter also da sind letztendlich
chancen ohne ende geblieben gegeben ja
einfach der umgang mit menschen machen
wir besonders viel spaß
das war sehr viel über die waren leer
das war also man weiß nicht viel über
die ware allgemein weil wir auch selber
die verzehren vielleicht aber so hört
man auch wenn man damit arbeitet wo die
ware herkommt wieder hergestellt wird
oder wo zumal ich auch gebraucht ich
finde das tolle an dem beruf das waren
unheimlich viele möglichkeiten hat
weiterzukommen
eine selbstständige arbeit verrichten
kann und jemand der gerne ist und dazu
wackelig jetzt macht gutes glas wein
trinken möchte er ist einfach in so
einem supermarkt richtig aufgehoben